voilà la suite des images diffusés par
m6 tu as été au coeur de la polémique
c'est vrai que ça a été après tu as été
entendu par la police mais requises
ition tu as vécu un cauchemar
pierre-jean oui franchement c'était
c'est une histoire de fou un moment je
me suis dit ce que je suis encore en
france ou est ce que c'est la balle à la
quatrième dimension sassi quota des
choses que tu regrettes des choses que
tu as pu dire parce que oui ans que je
suis là ce qui t'a porté préjudice
c'est un moment a dit que tu avais
invité des ministres à dîner voilà et
quand vous utilisez ce que j'ai dit j'ai
dit à cette journaliste qui m'a appelé
directement parce que c'était une
conversation comme des assistants
m'appelle et elle m'a un peu énervé
parce qu'elle a fait six appels en
absence comme je t'aime expliqué et elle
me rappelle me rappelle je la rappelle
sur son portable ne répond pas à leurs
appels sur une ligne enregistrées ne me
dis pas que la conversation est
enregistrée
je me suis énervé comme puis c'est que
je me montre très vite la mesure comme
toi et un moment j'ai dit d'ailleurs
georges je déjeune régulièrement je dîne
régulièrement des restaurants
clandestins ou d'ailleurs je croise des
ministres mais j'ai d'ailleurs pas dit
que c'était des ministres en poste
c'était une boutade c'était une blague
et l'a7 enregistrait et sur une
conversation de six minutes
eh ben on a mis des images qui ne fait
pas chez moi on a mis des imans fin ça a
été ouais franchement ça a été à
certains rythmes la perquisition ça a
été dur pour toi pas du tout temps
arrêté charmant ils sont restés 25
minutes ils m'ont emmené sur sortie et
le lendemain matin quand a été entendu
oui l'adorable adorable j'ai des garçons
délicieux d'ailleurs yona il était
magnifique et son nom son prénom il est
superbe jeu nous en bas de la navette
c'est vrai que ça c'est pas traumatisant
pour toi ce qui sait pas si ça a été
traumatisant ouais bah écoute tu as tu
ne fais rien de mal tu essaies de te
sortir parce que ça fait 15 mois que tu
as une entreprise le palais vivienne une
société où t'as pas dead t'as rien parce
que t'as pas le bon bout le pont le bon
code ape et tu essaies de 2,2 d'appeler
des gens que tu connais on dit ballard
ouverture c'est en juin et en juillet
donc je me dis je vais préparer une soir
une soirée professionnelle avec des
chefs d'entreprise pour organiser des
visites et tout d'un coup on le
lendemain matin le lendemain je me vois
sur des écrans de télévision
s'excuse-t-elle peur que ça se termine
jamais que y'a un moment je mange et je
me suis dit je vais me flinguer ouais
c'est vrai a vraiment quand j'étais à
lyon
d'ailleurs à amiens que je remercie
beaucoup que mon directeur damien lopez
et avoir pensé à flinguer
oui parce que rien à un moment j'ai dit
mais qu'est ce qu'ils veulent l'année
dernière c'était pour une histoire de
photo
là c'est pour une histoire
ine mais qu'est ce que j'ai fait de mal
j'ai cette ville j'ai c'est de survivre
comme beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise
je ne suis pas le seul simplement je
suis connue médiatique people ce que tu
veux mais ouais ça a été dur ouest voilà
et pierre-jean vous regrettez toujours
mais c'est vous qui allume et le flou
permanent les affaires toutes les années
c'est pas de ma faute a lancé on veut
pas dire aujourd'hui non dans la
situation dans laquelle vivent tous les
français on peut pas dire que les
ministres qui vont dîners dans des
restaurants clandestins c'est normal ou
normal que tag la berge et moi c'est un
peu dérangeant
oui mais pierre jean j'ai l'impression
que tu parles de ton d'audition par
exemple on a raison tout en rigolant
disant déchargement richard il a raison
de lancer c'est pour moi j'aime l'argent
et après pierre jean vous avez fait en
revenant de l'inde de votre garde à vue
vous avez fait une vidéo le lundi au
soleil un homme jean castex été prise il
ya deux mois et demi et pas du tout
guillaume et vous voulez quoi qui
s'immolent par le feu c'est quoi mais
c'est vrai il a été minime en bâtiments
non mais c'est vrai maintenant mais ça
ne va pas il a été humilié
médiatiquement il a subi un tsunami
médiatique est dégueulasse et lui n'ont
pratiquement pas d'incriminer m6 que cet
homme a juste dîner avec des gens et que
ce sera tous pleinement légale dans
quelques semaines mais qu'il était une
humiliation
il ya plein de gens qui ont écouté son
affaire qui sont des restaurateurs
notamment et qui sont épiés groupe lui
est pas et pas même soir il y aurait lé
droit et pas nous et à chaque fois c'est
je fais des rétro pédalage jean-pierre
vous le savez je vous l'avais déjà dit
natacha
je vous l'avais déjà dit la dernière
fois ça fait des bébés dallage en disant
c'est pas de ma famille nommé l'instant
colère est vraiment chère à tous même
temps
pire jean est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
derrière toi c'est derrière moi m'a été
lavé ses invités laver et tout va très
bien je suis reparti sur les
bicentenaires je prépare des expositions
à droite à gauche au centre mieux le
palais vivienne rouvre ses portes on va
faire des visites
donc là ça y est c'est fini pour toi
tout est pour moi tout était ce qu'ils
ont dit l'artiste a dit anne laplante
j'étais avec mes avocats encore hier ils
mendient toute façon tu peux pas être
poursuivi pour vous ou pour quoi un
travail illégal j'ai pas organisé la
soirée j'ai pas touché à roue et mis en
danger de tournai donc tout ce qu'on a
dit qu'on a dit c'est de la calomnie
c'est absolument dégueulasse et qu'on a
voulu sourire la tête de chalencon comme
d'habitude mais c'est pas grave que
j'avais porté plainte oui je vais porter
plainte faisait donc là vous allez
porter plainte dans un deuxième temps
vous attendez oui parce que je voulais
avoir un petit peu ça sert à rien de
s'exciter mais oui je vais porter
plainte contre écrire la journée contre
mais pourquoi pour diffamation ah bah
déjà on n'aurait jamais dû enregistrer
cette conversation que c'est une
conversation qui a duré cinq minutes on
a en a extrait tu en plus ces gens se
sont introduits chez moi sans aucune
invitation avec des images tronquées et
volets suis désolé on m'a fait porter le
chapeau comme si je devais je faisais
payer les gens des centaines d'euros
j'ai jamais fait payer que qui que ce
soit d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
gens enfin tous mes amis savent que je
ne fais payer personnes au palais bielle
et c'est moi qui y dépenser qui fait la
bu la cuisine or gilles verdez
pierre-jean l'enquète se poursuit quand
même la brûle a balayé mais n'oublions
pas sûr qu'elle se poursuit quand même
il y aura peut-être des suites oui c'est
ce que vous annoncez jacques mesrine